Speaker 1: There are some Republicans, very
few who I still disagree with politically,
but they have the recognition and apparently
the common sense to see what the conservative
right wing Republican movement has been taken
over by in the United States. And to say these
people are morons. One such person who literally
used that word is Mitt Romney, and we're going to
talk about that a little bit later. But first,
we're going to take a tour through CPAC. CPAC,
the conservative Political Action Conference was
in Orlando, Florida, over the weekend, and we
already looked at Donald Trump's speech, which was
outrageous, completely outrageous and corrosive
to democracy in every way. But I want to now just
show you that it was not an anomaly or an anomaly.
Whatever your preference is on the pronunciation,
both are correct despite me being criticized,
no matter which of the two I use. No, but in all
seriousness, it was. It was just all completely
bonkers. Here is radical Republican Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert saying she has already filed
articles of impeachment against Biden, Kamala
Harris and Nancy Pelosi. Is that even true?
And if so, like what are they for? She doesn't say
Speaker 3: solution that I have put forward.
The paper work's already been filed.
Speaker 1: She's filed it already. We
haven't heard, I guess, but she's filed it.
Speaker 3: I have introduced articles of
impeachment to impeach Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris. Get Nancy Pelosi the
Unidentified: heck out of
there and save our country.
God bless you all. I'll see you next year.
Speaker 1: This is a perfect example of,
I'm going to say something loudly and people will
clap and the words could be anything, right? I
mean, she could have just said, I have just filed
for sending the first humans to Jupiter's great
I. And people go, You're OK. I mean, it's
whatever. It's just it's just the tone. And
speaking of tone. This is bizarre. Remember Larry
Kudlow, Trump's economic adviser? He couldn't
possibly be lower energy. He went up on stage.
He spoke, speaking like someone a minute before
coming on stage, just told him someone had died
close to him or something lit. This is, I guess,
this is supposed to inspire people. Look at this
Speaker 2: subpoena free and I got a new job.
With FOX Business. Yeah. So if you
watch our show, it's called Kudlow.
Please watch the show. But what part of the show?
Speaker 1: Measures pretty good.
Speaker 2: Here's the thing.
We have adopted a mantra, I have adopted a
mantra. For the show. Yeah, but for everything.
And it's called Save America. Right? That is what
I want to talk to you about today. Save America.
Speaker 1: Okay. The I don't I don't
know who appears more comatose the
the audience or Larry Kudlow, really a bundle
of energy, as you can see. Then you may have
heard that Papa John, this is John Schnatter.
He's the guy from the Papa John's pizza company
who was very much against Obamacare. He said, You
know, if I have to give everybody health care,
it's going to sort of cost me like 10 cents a
pizza. And he was very, very strongly against
it. A conservative thought leader, you might
be able to say. He suggests Biden goaded Putin
into invading Ukraine in order to distract
from the so-called real issues, which is quite
a quite a big brain conspiracy theory.
Speaker 2: Here we go. Ministration my
administration totally incompetent or they do
this intentionally. When you cut off our pipeline
and you open up Russia's and you give the guy a
seven hundred and fifty billion dollars looks to
me like it's pretty intentional. But what a great
smokescreen. What a great distraction from all the
real issues here that are affecting Americans. So
I think it's a smokescreen of it was intentional.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it was intentional to create a
smokescreen, says conservative thought leader Papa
John about what's happening geopolitically and
foreign relations exactly then. And this is where
if you thought this was crazy, then it
gets really crazy. The Missouri State
Attorney General, Eric Schmidt, says the
Constitution would soon be replaced by the
Communist Manifesto if Democrats got their way.
Speaker 2: They want to replace the Declaration of
Independence with a Communist Manifesto, right?
Speaker 1: That's obviously untrue. There are
essentially no communists in power in the United
States. There are certainly some Social Democrats.
I guess there's a couple Democratic Socialists,
although even they seem confused as to whether
they're really democratic socialists, people like
Bernie and AOC. I don't know that they're even
really democratic socialist. So why would the
Communist Manifesto be put anywhere? It doesn't
make sense. CPAC Speaker Charles Herbstreit,
who's a candidate for governor in Nebraska.
This is unbelievable. He, the Republicans over the
weekend realized pushing pushing Putin is bad. We
got to be pro Ukraine. They don't really care one
way or the other. They just want to do what sells.
And so now they've started saying Ukraine is
the good guy. And so Charles Herbstreit asks
the crowd to kneel and say a prayer for Ukraine,
and the camera cuts to the audience. And nobody,
nobody cares. Certainly nobody's kneeling,
but it's it's wild. They just don't care.
Speaker 2: I'm going to ask all of
you to do a favor, even if it's a
little uncomfortable. Yeah. You with your
spouse is here. Kneel down and give a prayer
for what's taking place in
Speaker 1: Ukraine, right?
First of all, so far, it's not clear whether he
wants them to pray for the innovations continue
or for it to stop. It's sort of unclear
from this so far, but let's keep going.
Speaker 2: We may need our prayers. Yeah,
that Zelensky character. He's a hero, right?
Speaker 1: A mild, very muted
applause and certainly nobody praying
a couple of the panels that they had. One of them
is lock her up for real, referring, of course,
to Hillary Clinton. This is beyond parody.
Speaker 3: Ladies and gentlemen, it's time
for lock her up for real.
Speaker 2:
Oh, my God.
Speaker 1: And then
here's another very, very hard hitting panel.
Speaker 3: Ladies and gentlemen, this is
fire forcing a series of curated
Speaker 1: speeches
here at very, very carefully curated.